so there's an article in The Daily wire
yesterday about the former first lady
Michelle Obama maybe you remember her
she was at a some kind of women's
conference and she was having a
conversation on stage with an actress
from the show black dish the actresses
named Tracee Ellis Ross never heard of
her but she's an actress apparently and
the women were lamenting the fact that
girls still dream of weddings and they
still dream of prince charming this is a
problem in the eyes of Michelle Obama
this other woman the two agreed that
some women Tracee Ellis Ross apparently
included can sacrifice family for the
sake of a career and for professional
ambition and for success and be happy as
a clam it's a perfectly legitimate fine
great choice that a woman can make in
fact it would seem that mrs. Obama who
is married with two kids you may
remember thinks that this path is
actually preferable given the fact that
she considers it a problem that girls
aspire to get married and have kids she
wouldn't call it a problem if a young
girl said she wanted to grow up to be an
astronaut or a CEO of a fortune 500
company that wouldn't be a problem but
if a girl says she wants to get married
and have kids and that's what she's
dreaming of Michelle Obama's mind and in
the minds of a lot of feminists and a
lot of people in our culture that is a
problem
it's an it's an interesting thing
because Americans are increasingly
looking outside of the home for
happiness they're there we have fled the
home in search of happiness and in
search of fulfillment and the people who
have rejected family life for the sake
of a job they'll say they'll claim that
oh yeah I found it my life is wonderful
I'm so happy in fact um Ross said she
provided during this interview or
whatever was she provided some
compelling evidence to prove that her
decision to forego family life for the
sake of a job was the right call she
said she turned to the audience and she
said look where I'm sitting right
because she's sitting she's on stage and
she's sitting next to the former first
lady which that of course is the peak
and pinnacle of all happiness and so
that proves that look my life is great
wonderful I'm a 45 year old woman I have
no kids I have no family but I my life
is so awesome and we're always told this
the the child free people are always
telling us how wonderful and graded just
awesome and exciting their life is which
is the first hint that their life is not
so great because when someone feels the
need to constantly tell you their life
is great and they're happy it means
their life is not great and they are not
happy and I am talking here specifically
about the quote child free that is
people who they don't say child list
they say child free because child list
makes it sound like they're missing
something
child free makes it sound like a child
is a disease that they're free from
so I'm talking about the people who
choose to forego family to forego kids
for the sake of just a job and
professional success that's what I'm
talking about
I'm addressing that because that is what
Michelle Obama is pushing it's what a
lot of people are pushing in our society
I'm discussing that I'm not talking
about people who aren't unable to
conceive children or people who are
never able to get married even though
they want to or they choose not to get
married for the sake of some other
vocation not discussing that I'm
specifically talking about the people
who choose this life of
self-centeredness okay just to clarify
here so you know who I'm talking about
and the people who make that choice
again they're all they're always
insisting that their life is so great
and it's just it's it's so it's so great
in this it's just so straightforwardly
great the way they present it is they
never have any feelings of loneliness
whatsoever none no it's awesome remember
there's this you wait you may remember
the Time magazine cover a cover story on
Time magazine a few years ago and it was
about cover about the child free life
and there was a picture of these two
this married couple smiling on the beach
kicking back in the sand and they were
you know they were just so happy and
then the headline there said when having
it all means not having kids and that's
the way it's presented they have it all
they've got everything and they're just
happy laying on the beach and that is
what the child free life is it is just a
life on the beach no sadness at all it's
utopia
and yet
when I look around society
I don't really see a lot of evidence of
happiness I will in fact what I see is a
depressed anxious stressed out nation of
addicts and narcissists and people who
are who compulsively stare at their
phones and and watch TV their entire
life is lived on screens and they're
popping antidepressants I mean that's
what I see when I look around I don't
see this I don't see people who are
living in bliss I hear sometimes people
claim that they are and they present
themselves as if they are on Instagram
or on Time magazine covers or when
they're giving interviews or when
they're talking with the with with with
a first lady onstage at a women's
conference I could I hear that but when
I look around I don't see any evidence
of it I see a bunch of just zombies
walking around who barely just confused
and lost and feeling hopeless that's
what I see and that isn't to say that
all unhappy people are childless it's a
lot of unhappy people with children what
I'm saying is that
we have a very flawed idea about
happiness and our our concept of how you
attain happiness
which is in our minds you attain it
selfishly through self-centered pursuits
through pursuing things for your own
sake that clearly has not worked out as
much as we claim that it has worked out
it hasn't
we are more depressed and anxious now
than we've ever been in history but
probably the most depressed anxious
country in the history of the world and
so obviously we're not going about
things in the right way
there's cot wit which is with everything
about our modern attitudes and our
modern philosophies there's constantly
this disconnect between what is claimed
and what is actually happening
we're told that okay we adopt this
philosophy this way of life and then X Y
Z will happen but then I look around and
X Y Z is not happening the exact
opposite is happening now there are some
studies that that will insist that
people without kids are in fact much
happier than people with kids if you
google it right now I'm sure there are
people furiously googling it so they can
disprove me with science and they can
leave a comments like no Matt
scientifically you're wrong okay because
science has measured human happiness and
fulfillment and you see it's been
tabulated here on this bar graph and
obviously clearly you're wrong and if
you google it you will find you'll see a
headline saying that the people without
kids are way happier way happier than
people with kids
there's a problem with these kinds of
studies number one they assume an honest
self-assessment the only way to measure
someone's happiness is just to ask them
are you happy with your life choices is
your life it didn't you know are you
happy with the path you've taken has it
worked out for you do you feel fulfilled
all you can do is ask them and it would
require people who have sacrificed
family for career it would require them
to look honestly at their lives and at
themselves and to assess it
most people don't have the courage for
that so instead they'll just say oh yeah
sure I'm so happy
they're not trying to convince us
they're trying to convince themselves
primarily the second problem is that a
study you know these kind of studies
they in surveys they assume that people
have a correct understanding of
happiness which most people don't most
people don't know what happiness is so
you don't know how to find it and they
don't even they're unhappy but they
don't even know that they are unhappy
because they don't they don't understand
what happiness is they don't in other in
other words they don't know what they're
missing
they don't know what they could have and
what sort of happiness and joy they
could actually attain because all
they've ever gone for is just this
shallow selfish immediate kind of
pleasure and indulgence that's all
they've ever gone for it's all you've
ever had so they say oh yeah well I
guess that's happiness it's not
it would be like if you if you wanted to
find out whether or not whether people
who exercise are happier or less happy
than people don't exercise and so you go
to a guy on a treadmill
who's on like mile three of the
treadmill and he's sweating and he's
just he's exhausted and you go up and
you ask him in the moment hey are you
happy right now
and the guy is uncomfortable and is in
pain and he wants to get off the
treadmill but he told himself he'd do
five miles so right now in this moment
he's probably not he would not
self-identify as happy
and then let's say then you you go and
you'll find a guy who's sitting on a
couch eating Cheetos and he's on our
five of a Netflix binge and you ask him
are you happy right now probably as he's
relaxing on the couch and just sitting
there on his butt he'll probably say oh
yeah I'm so happy I'm just I'm relaxing
it's great I'm happy
does that actually prove which path
brings greater happiness
or does that prove that the guy on the
couch is deluded and numb and the guy on
the treadmill is working for something
greater and bigger than what the guy on
the couch is working for so maybe if
you're doing your survey you should wait
a couple hours wait till the guys off
the treadmill after a day spent eating
healthy and getting exercise after an
active full day ask him then and then
asked the guy who spent all day watching
TV as he's finally fading off to bed
with his brain half melted ask him ask
them then how happy they are better yet
come back in a few years come back in a
few years when the guy on the treadmill
has been working out and exercising and
and beating being healthy this whole
time and now he's older but he's in
great physical shape and he doesn't have
a lot of health problems that people his
age have and then go to the guy who's
been sitting on the couch the whole time
and he's overweight he's fat he's got
diabetes
but let's do a comparison then
to find out who's happier
who chose the better path likewise I'd
be interested to see a follow-up study
with one of these happy people one of
these happy child free people I'd be
interested to see a follow-up study of a
couple decades from now
take some woman who shows
profession career success over family
over kids yeah right now when she's
relaxing and she's getting ready for
ready for her third vacation of the year
yeah maybe she'll say oh I'm so happy
check back in a couple decades
when she's alone
maybe she was married before but people
who marry and choose not to have kids
their likelihood of divorce is much much
higher than people who do have kids so
she's probably divorced by now and she's
55 60 years old
she's on the tail end of her career
a lot of her high-flying ambitions have
long since given way to reality she's
being replaced by younger more skilled
people and she comes home everyday to
her great wonderful nice house that the
housekeeper has kept in great shape and
she's got all this nice stuff there all
this nice wonderful stuff but nobody
there to use it
and she's got all this space but nobody
to fill it with that all these rooms but
no one to sleeping
patience she wants but she's been on all
the exotic vacations they've lost their
novelty by now and also frankly it's
kind of depressing to go on vacation by
yourself
and most the people at work are much
younger than her but the people that she
knows her friends or her age most of
them are there planning weddings for the
grown children they're going to baptisms
for their grandchildren they're planning
with family reunions they have all these
landmarks coming up they've got the
grandchildren coming over over on the
weekend they're gonna go over a picnic
they're gonna go down to the lake
they've got this whole thing planned
and her all she's got is herself
or loneliness
her success
ask ask her then how happy she is and
and and then maybe come back
a couple decades from then which is
elderly
in a nursing home
and there's nobody there to care for her
she never had any kids
and so she's alone and then come back
when she's on her deathbed
she's dying alone with nobody there to
mourn
because she has no family
ask her then how happy she is
she's leaving no legacy behind except
for the work she did at some job some
job that's long since forgotten her
even if she had success she worked for a
great big company and she became a
manager and she managed people she had
an office she had everything I mean she
was if she had an office Wow
but that's not a legacy because she left
that job and she was immediately
replaced by someone else and the work
she did just didn't matter that much
that's the thing about a job about being
an employee that's why it's so
ridiculous for us to worship it as some
great achievement you work at a job you
can be replaced in an instant like that
whatever your job is that's what I hate
to tell you this I'm it's for true for
me too
whatever your job is you can be replaced
like that and nobody will even notice
maybe they'll give you maybe if you if
you retire they'll throw a nice party
for you if you get fired and when you're
walking out the door holding your box of
stuff maybe they'll say oh so we'll miss
you I'm so sorry to see you leave they
won't miss you by tomorrow they'll
forgotten about you and things will just
continue along without you
it's different when you have a family
they've got kids when you have a spouse
you love you got grandchildren you've
got a whole family you're not
replaceable
when you leave they mourn you something
real is missing when you leave a job
nothing real is missing
there's no legacy it doesn't matter
so ask her then how happy she is
has anyone in the history of mankind is
any dying person in the history of
mankind ever lay on their deathbed
said to themselves I am so happy that I
sacrificed family for material
possessions has any dying person ever in
history felt that way
of course there are many people who do
have kids and yet follow a similar
trajectory to the one I've just
described there are many people who have
families and yet still sacrifice their
families for the sake of for the sake of
professional ambition and success and
they're also going to end up alone and
miserable
their kids were raised by TVs and by
babysitters because both parents were
out working ten hours a day to just
amass all of this wealth and all of
these possessions and all of this
success and they feel like it's okay and
their kids aren't missing anything
because at least they can go on a nice
vacation to Disney World once a year and
they can buy them a lot of nice toys for
Christmas and birthdays
but in the end there the kids are being
neglected and they're missing the one
thing they really need which is a family
which is parents who are there for them
now I'm not saying there are people who
or fall on tough Financial Times and so
both parents have really have to work
for the sake of in order to in order to
make ends meet and they're just
struggling and doing what they can there
are a lot of people in that position
and and on some level the kids will you
know maybe not now but at some age when
the kids get older they're gonna look at
that they look at the way their parents
had to do struggling and fighting and
they're gonna respect that they're gonna
know that they were not neglected what
I'm talking about which is very common
especially an upper-middle class America
I'm talking about families that are
well-off and plenty of money one you
know the the dad on his own is making
plenty of money to care for the film but
still
both parents just go out and their
primary concern is their careers
that's the case and a lot of families
for the parents that's the main thing
they're worried about those are their
priorities
you
and the problem is that the kids as they
get older are going to realize that and
they're gonna see that they play second
fiddle to the stupid jobs that their
parents have
and their kids are gonna grow to resent
them
and as those parents get older and
probably they're gonna have divorce too
because their priorities are out of
whack and they care more about their
jobs than they do about their families
which leads to divorce it also leads to
affairs and all kinds of things so most
likely that marriage isn't going to last
and both those parents are gonna end up
alone as well and as they get older and
they look back and they see all that
time that was wasted and they see that
now their kids are older now and don't
need them anymore and they look back and
realize that man all this time I could
have been spending time with my family
taking I'm fishing building treehouses
doing all this stuff with them reading
them books making memories I didn't do
any of that and now they're going to
want to try to forge a relationship and
all of a sudden now become real parents
to their kids but their kids are gonna
look at them and say it's too late for
that we don't have any connection
there's no bond there never will be you
had a chance to build it and you never
did you had a chance to be a parent and
you never did and now you want to be a
friend it's not going to work that way
you
and so they're gonna be alone and
they're essentially going to die alone
too
and the words that are said about them
at their eulogies by their kids will be
perfunctory and half-hearted
as their kids struggle to conjure up any
warm memories
to mention in tribute to them
you
there's a lot of people in America who
are on this path of just loneliness and
disappointment
because a lot of people have been made
to believe that professional achievement
is the highest goal in life it's the
whole point of life
to achieve professionally to have
success that's what we think is the
point
but it's not
the way that we find you if you really
want to find happiness and fulfillment
and meaning in life you don't find it
through a job
you find I know this sounds corny but it
only sounds corny to us because we were
silly and selfish people you find
purpose joy and meaning in service to
others service to God first and then to
your family and then after that to
neighbors and communities in that order
everyone in the world is called to
dedicate their lives to service everyone
is called to that and only those who
heed that calling will find any meaning
any purpose any real joy in their lives
and it is quite possible that you have
people who are called to serve in
another capacity there are people who
never get married and so they you know
they they enter into a different
vocation and they serve in a different
way they feel called to serve
differently and to enter into the
religious life to become missionaries I
mean whatever they but they serves
through some other way there are people
in that and that's a beautiful wonderful
thing and and those people will find
meaning and joy and purpose in their
lives and they're gonna leave behind a
legacy
and then there are married couples who
can't have kids and so they become
parents some other way maybe through
adoption which is which is wonderful I
also I met a married couple once who
discovered that they couldn't conceive
children and so they went over season
became missionaries and became kind of
spiritual parents to a whole host of
people and they also are leaving a
legacy they're finding meaning and joy
and purpose in their lives and that's a
great thing it is possible to have a
family and not to serve it just as it is
possible to not have a family and yet to
serve
nobody's suggesting otherwise I'm
certainly not what I am suggesting is
twofold number one most people are
called to have Femmes and so it is
objectively a bad thing that we treat
family life as kind of this afterthought
and the average age of first marriage
for men now is like 30 and the average
age of having a kid is though is being
pushed back further and further it would
be one thing if a few people if some
people took that path and waited longer
but when you get to the point where
everybody is putting it off and waiting
to start families until they're out of
their young adulthood and out of their
20s that means that our priorities as a
society is that our priorities have just
been flipped upside down everything's
been turned upside down because we're
putting professional achievement and
financial security ahead
of femme
so that's what I'm saying I'm also
saying
nobody is called to just have a career
and to have that be their life
because if you have no family or if
you're married but you both work and you
have no kids then your career is just
about you it's just about sustaining you
it's about money for you it's about
achievements for you it's about success
for you
what it's about and you might say well I
help people in my career I provide a
product or a service or whatever great I
mean really great that's that's awesome
but when you go work a job the primary
point is is the money you wouldn't do it
for free right
something for if your career is
something you do for free to help others
well that's different that's a that's a
ministry but most people their career is
primarily they do it to make money for
themselves
they have a family they do it for their
family but if there's no family they're
just doing it for themselves and that's
not a life that's not how that's that's
not a life of meaning and purpose
that's just a life about you
and the average American who says I'm
putting off family for career or I'm not
having a family because I'm focusing on
my career the average person who says
that it's not because they want to help
people despite what they might say that
is they're looking to help people it's
because they want money for themselves
and they want stuff for themselves they
want nice vacations and they want to
avoid the hassle and the hardship that
comes with having kids because we've
decided you know what we think is that
finding happiness you find happiness
through avoiding suffering and avoiding
hardship and avoiding sacrifice and we
don't realize that that's not where you
find happiness you find happiness
through hardship overcoming it in the
midst of it that's where you find
happiness so if you spend your whole
life trying to go around hardship and
sacrifice you're gonna miss it because
it's right there in the middle you got a
plunge in and find it
so that's where you fly it happen it's
not and in look if you don't
of a family then there are things you
can do that those of us with with kids
can't do as much you can go on nice
vacations and everything
but even that
even that is empty and meaningless
if that's all your life is you know I
have the opportunity as part of my job
to travel all across the country when
I'm doing speaking gigs and I see lots
of different sites and it's great but
when I go and I buy myself
in some new locations seeing some
beautiful view or making some great
memory you know it's the first thing I
always think to myself is man I wish my
wife was here man I wish my kids were
here to see this and to share this
memory
I can appreciate the thing on my own and
I do but how much greater would it be if
I could share it with the people that I
love how much greater is the happiness
when you share it
you
how much greater is happiness when it's
not just about you
there's a reason why a lot of people who
in our society who have families and
have kids will still report that they're
miserable and it's awful and they'll
complain about it
because even though they have families
they're still selfish people and they're
shallow and they're cowardly really
so they're not able to find a happiness
that isn't about them
but the real happiness and family life
and it is a real happiness
you find that when you're not looking
for when it's not about you
you find it in the moments that are not
centered around you
you find it in the moments that you give
to your family and to your spouse that's
where you find that real true happiness
but if you never give yourself to them
you never give them any time
ever sacrifice anything for them
then you're never gonna find the
happiness in family life your going to
miss it
there's a movie called into the wild
about Christopher McCandless a true
story and he was the guy he left society
behind he burned his driver's license
credit credit cards he walked across the
country on foot ultimately into the
Alaskan wilderness wilderness by himself
and when he made it there to this
beautiful place he accidentally ate
poison berries and he ultimately died
alone out in the woods and as he was
dying he scrawled a message for whoever
would find his body and the message said
happiness is only real when shared
and that is a profound truth
if your whole life is about making
yourself happy
you will never be happy
not a real happiness
the real happiness is that which is
shared
the happiness you find in family life is
complicated difficult challenging even
painful but it's real it's real and it's
worth it
really pity those who forgo it for the
sake of mere selfishness now even more
pity those who have the opportunity to
experience that happiness because they
have families yet they miss it because
they can't stop looking in the mirror
what a waste I mean what an utter total
waste
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed